this evening we're going to take a look
at character categories and I hope it's
going to be fun I think it will be fun I
have I picked six six particular
categories I obviously I can't do all 14
in one night we will be falling asleep
here but we will talk it through and
what what the examples are and I picked
examples for specific reasons I'll tell
you when we get there some like for
instance some adversary characters in
major motion pictures are pretty obvious
right and therefore I picked one that
isn't obvious so you can see the other
side of it too okay
now then perspective Erik does like the
Greeks doesn't he what is character you
know in a screenplay or a novel and they
are both important because they are very
different and we'll get to that in a
second about 400 BC what's his name feel
frost Asst Theophrastus was a Greek
philosopher and he sat down and made up
this list it was about you know 70 types
long but made up a list of types of
people based upon predominant
predominant attitudes flatterer
garrulous boor reckless superstitious
and so forth I'm not quite sure why he
did it because he was a philosopher not
a dramatist but it just turned out that
one of his students was named Menander
and Menander as some of you obviously
woops Menander went on to make a career
out of writing somewhere around 100
comedy plays based upon these character
types using the types of people in
exaggerated form too
create comic characters Menander
basically was the first comedy writer
first playwright comedy writer in
history as far as we know and he did
quite well he had a good career at it
but attitude types do not relate to plot
function and what we must concern
ourselves with and obviously as I
eliminate other possibilities here we're
talking about plot function and that is
where we go to the 14 character
categories early on I mean this was
Moliere was doing this you know to
almost 2,000 years later using the types
the exaggerated types all of which was
swell
but the plots were not necessarily
dependent upon those characters feeding
into them okay I just typed in character
categories and googled it and this is
what came back this is contemporary this
is a few months ago round character flat
characters stock character one
dimensional three dimensional but again
this has nothing to do and misses
completely story purpose and that's what
we're looking for the story purpose of
characters because the storytelling
function of a character in film is
critical it's absolutely critical work
even more critical than it is in novels
right so every character present in your
screenplays and scripts other scripts
they have to be there to serve the plot
the story and moving it forward and
there's only two ways that they can
serve a story they either are there to
help or to hinder the progress of the
hero that's it and let me tell you this
is this is why that is true okay and
then we have to back up a bit and I have
I have had lots of students through the
years who come in with
attitudes towards story and character
that they have learned from teachers and
professors of English and of literature
and in other words from novels and the
difference between novels and motion
picture visual storytelling couldn't be
more extreme and plan and separate
absolutely separate first of all here is
how a novel works number one it is
subjective subjective they are it is
always an interior monologue which means
there is a narrator writing it or
talking it and talking to you the reader
that makes it subjective it is the
opinion of one person basically and even
when the story is written in third
person or third person omniscient you
know like the voice of somebody looking
down from heaven upon the scene and
describing everything and then jumping
from inside the head and feelings of one
character to inside the head and
feelings of another character that too
is completely subjective because some
God is narrating it too in writing in
novels
you've got sentences in paragraph and
they can own at paragraphs and they can
only focus on one thing at a time
what a sentence describes the sunset and
describes the way the trees are blowing
in the breeze or whatever it is and then
the next single thing gets addressed one
thing at a time so what happens is well
it only works in that the reader
provides everything else from your own
memories your own oh yeah I remember
then you kind of fill in the details and
help create that fictional world of the
novel in your own imagination and that
too is subjective the whole process here
of reading and enjoying a novel and
experiencing that story is subjective
three novels can take side trips they
don't have to be
read in one sitting they can and will
try war and peace you're going to be
having several sittings to get through
it yes but that means there's less focus
on plot not always but in general it is
looser
it is looser the plot thing is looser
let me see I was just thinking about
Ernest Hemingway book but for Whom the
Bell Tolls anybody read it grand total
of one okay I know it's another era of
another era I was I was a Hemingway a
fan when I was in my teens you know and
I compulsively read them all kind of
stuff but for Whom the Bell Tolls is a
really great book but the main story is
it takes place in revolutionary Spain in
the mid 30s just before World War two
Francisco Franco as a dictator - had
taken over Spain and the rebels were in
the mountains fighting to return to
democracy and that's the main plot but
there is one character in it by the name
of Pilar a woman by the name of Pilar as
I recall she was she's about 50 years
old
I can't remain that's the image that
still the subjective image that still
stays with me all these years later
right but she's taking all the risks of
all the other people she risks death
every day when they go into battle and
so forth but Hemingway grew so fond of
her that for almost 90 pages he takes a
sidestep and writes her entire story and
her entire backstory and it's wonderful
I mean it's him writing prose which is
wonderful by definition and then some 80
or 90 pages later he comes back to the
main plot and continues you cannot do
that in visual storytelling that is a
quality only available in novels
in literature or form you can't do that
plot can be looser because it's not
limited to two hours only and has to be
seen in one sitting
describes feelings and thoughts that you
know the narrator goes from inside the
feelings and thoughts of one and
describes them and describes the other
so we can subjectively know people's
emotions okay now here's the movies film
is exactly the opposite visual
storytelling is as utterly objective as
novels are subjective when we go into a
theater and sit down and the movie
begins everybody in that audience sees
exactly the same thing every everybody
there is we don't bring our own
imagination to it we see the exact same
thing everything has been decided the
set the the lighting the costumes the
blocking everything is taken care of and
does not require our imagination to feed
over it and secondly instead of one
thing at a time motion pictures give to
us a deluge of information all at once
hundreds of individual there's motion
and there's color and there's speech and
there's action physical action and it's
all happening at once and that's why
it's such an overwhelming art form it is
the most overwhelming and / you know
personally involving art form so far
that there is in the world because of
this deluge of information no side trips
you got basically you got approximately
two hours to tell your story beginning
to end and then everybody goes home it's
not done in small little bites like you
would read a novel over time it has to
be complete in two hours and that means
no side trips none and because it is
utterly objective that means the only
way we learn
really about character is by what they
do behavior in film is character in
novels that can be describing go inside
and you know this and that is going on
inside no sir you don't you can't do
that I'm not saying that there isn't
dialogue and people can say ouch because
they're feeling pain or something but
for us to know it and to share it it has
to be behavior which can be seen
three-dimensional visual and that is why
when you build a story a visual story
you are providing the plot that will
allow your characters but specifically
your your key character to take this
journey and demonstrate who they are and
demonstrate how they grow and how they
change by the end that is very
completely different really then then
novels okay therefore all characters
must serve the ends of in that two hours
making that hero's journey his or her
trip through whatever your story is they
must feed into that and they have to
either help or hinder the hero and
simultaneously be providing conflict
visible present tense conflict so that's
how we arrive at the 14 character
categories now you saw this last time
here it is again and I just want to run
these past you one more time these are
in the book no these are in the book
don't worry about that but uh this is
the first half of them and tonight I've
got examples of hero adversary love
interest sidekick mentor and endangered
innocent the gate Guardian we will save
its it's usually more of a lesser part
than the others and we'll save it for
another time and then these are the
other seven
and these we will get to over time as we
analyze the pictures that we're going to
be looking at right although I'll say
off the top of my head adversary agent
is extremely important because most
adversaries have helped and that helped
the ones who do the bidding of and take
the orders from in one way or the other
the adversary
they are adversary agents and there's
various ramifications of who that can be
but that is the purpose storytelling
purpose they serve and down here it's
not really last on the list in terms of
importance at all I don't know how it
arrived down here but the helper
follower allies of the hero are people
who do the same but for the hero helper
followers there's all kinds of different
lungs Ocean's eleven that's a one hero
movie Danny ocean is the hero he has a
sidekick rusty that's another category
we're going to take a look at and then
he has his team all those other guys the
the terrific you smaller parts but they
are key to the enterprise and they are
all helper follower allies okay beyond
the 14 characters of course you have
atmosphere characters the under fives or
the extras they don't really have a
category I haven't given them a category
here because they do not serve a direct
plot storytelling function what they are
saying it crassly I suppose are props
they are there to make the world they're
there for verisimilitude to make the
world this fictional world for this
particular story feel real and sometimes
they have a few lines you know the the
sassy waitress who you know has a quick
quick cute quip and drops the bill and
we never see her again she has no story
function it's just milieu just to give
it depth and they don't advance the plot
and something else that's useful about
having the character categories is once
you assign a role to one of your
characters and pick them out of because
all of these can provide subplots all of
them once you pick a particular
individual and you paint them and create
them and make them three-dimensional and
once they are in a category they have to
stay in that category you can't change
categories okay
when it happens and I've seen it happen
a few times and it just destroys movies
what's it called the deep end anybody
seen the deep end Tilda Swinton I think
stars in well that alone tells you
something it starts out very interesting
and it's about Tilda Swinton who whose
son who is you know late teens and
applying to college and something
happens and and then all of a sudden it
looks like it's going to ruin his entire
life and there's bad guys and gangsters
trying to blackmail mom and she's
running around trying to fix it and set
it all right but a very strange thing
happens at the midpoint of that movie
his mom just kind of gives up and falls
in a frump and one of the adversary
agent characters who works for the bad
guy at the midpoint decides to take up
the flag of hero and all of a sudden the
mantle of hero changes from her to
someone else and he is the one who goes
forward and resolves the story and it
doesn't work it eliminates the emotional
connection we have with the characters
it's changing horses midstream and
psychologically for your audience it
just doesn't work